sorry this video took so long I had
never actually seen the child's play
movies before so I went ahead and binge
them so that I can properly analyze the
trailer for you and now I'm kind of
realizing that I probably didn't have to
but I did notice some interesting stuff
in the trailer and the website set up
for the fictional company within the
movie so stick around to the end of this
video if you want to hear about it the
beginning of the child's play trailer
plays as a commercial for this company
chasm a tech company that makes coffee
machines robotic vacuum cleaners tablets
VR games robots and toys if it's been a
while since you watch the original
series the company behind that was
called playpal toys so this is not the
same company all signs point to this
being a reimagining of the original so
if the original had taken place and the
tens or whatever the decade is called
this is how it might have gone down so
the good guy dolls from the 1980s film
are now called buddy because for some
reason lower case eyes are really
popular this millennium I should
probably just change my channel name to
be spelled like this here's our new Andy
Barclay and in the background there's a
photo of him and his father in the
original child's play and he does have a
deceased father but we never really know
anything about it when we first see Andy
it appears that he's rocking some
wireless headphones however there's
another shot later in the trailer where
it's evident that it's just his left ear
and every time we see the left ear it
has this device which has to be his
hearing it because those are popular in
horror movies now but in this movie the
hearing aid could be subject to wireless
interference from Chucky as a new 21st
century way for Chucky to attack Andy in
fact you can actually go to the website
on the side of the box
gasbuddy.com where there are more clues
about Chucky's capabilities it's
emphasized in the logo which contains
the Wi-Fi symbol telling us that
Internet connectivity plays a big part
in this new doll and it'll connect to
tablets computers and cell phones Chucky
is going to be connected to this Caslon
ecosystem of smart devices and I think
the horror in this movie is going to be
a commentary about how smart-home
devices are becoming something that we
trust and rely on too much look at this
text your new best friend connects to
and controls all your Caslon products
and smart home devices not you control
your doll and devices the doll is the
one controlling the devices this company
is in control of your home
your life look at this picture Chucky
has control over your computer your fans
and your sound system which I'm sure
ties right back to the fact that Andy
has a hearing aid he's also seen
manipulating a Smart TV and a drone
which brings to mind the scene from
child's play 3 where the CEO is attacked
by all of the toys in his home including
an RC helicopter this website also
suggests that buddy uses AI to interpret
human behavior which makes me think that
instead of the Chucky doll being
possessed by video like it is in the
original the doll will be possessed by
hackers who load a malicious code into
the buddy doll maybe Charles Lee ray is
actually a cyber criminal in this movie
the last item of note on this website is
the fact that buddy comes loaded with
the ability to communicate in English
and Spanish Andy's mother is played by
actress Aubrey Plaza in this movie who
has a Puerto Rican background so her and
her son aren't gonna be safe from keys
dropping by Chucky no matter which
language they're speaking let's talk
about possible Easter eggs the warehouse
of Buddy dolls bears great resemblance
to the good guy doll storage in the
factory at the end of child's play to
the crime scene shows a covered body
surrounded by broken glass as if
somebody had fallen from a window which
calls back to the original child's play
where Aunt Maggie becomes the first
victim of Chucky at least in his doleful
this might be the fall actually
happening and you may notice the caslen
logo on the truck in the background
meaning this accident would have taken
place at the factory or a distributor
whatever's going on here brings
reminders of Andy and Kyle in the
factory seen from child's play
- and when Chucky initially grabs his
clothes I noticed a drill on the table
which is one of the weapons used in cult
of Chucky this movie will take place in
the winter around Christmas time like
the original although it does not seem
like they stuck with Chicago for the
setting unfortunately I don't recognize
this license plate but it's most similar
to Idaho or a South Dakota alternative
one thing I personally found interesting
was the fact that when Andy first
unwraps the doll we're seeing from
Chucky's point of view as if he's
already on and gathering information
before they even opened the box now you
may remember in the first movie Chucky
had to go back to find Andy Barclay and
take over his body because he was the
first one Chucky revealed himself too so
maybe in the new movie Chucky is
programmed to go after the owner of the
doll and the facial recognition
determines who that actually is Chucky
is shown to be wielding his classic
knife in this movie but there are some
new modern weapons showcased in this
trailer like the ability to turn off the
lights and give a new meaning to Black
Friday shopping and maybe even taking
control of a self-driving car developed
by caslen at the end of the trailer
you're prompted to click on the next
video which is a special announcement
video from the caslen corporation which
you may or may not have already noticed
that the logo contains a blue eye just
like that of Chucky the announcement
features Henry Castle the founder of the
caslen corporation and he gives an
introduction to the Buddy doll saying
that every child deserves a companion
the video description confirms that
buddy will use artificial intelligence
that encourages viewers to visit Caslon
Corp comm visiting the site reveals more
information about the company and their
technology like the use of HD cameras
and a paragraph about other sensors it
says Caslon hub and VR products become
equipped with state-of-the-art haptic
and accelerator technology to help you
thrive in the real world while also
immersing you in the imagination
the vast and ever-evolving virtual
reality landscape this means that
Chucky's ability to hunt down Andy has
received a major upgrade he'll have the
ability to learn the tendencies of
Andy's body movements to help him
predict what his victim is gonna do next
before he even does it there's also a
products page where we can take a closer
look at some of the other Caslon
products like their drone that looks
like a flying shark and can fly a
hundred miles an hour and track its
victims using advanced algorithm to
track the subject as it flies up to ten
thousand feet overhead if this thing is
tracking you you're never gonna be safe
there's also the vacuum that we sell on
the trailer it's hard to imagine that
being a threat to man but you never know
the Caslon k1 speakers have the
capability to track your movements to
ensure location focused personalized
sound reproductions and this is what I
think Chucky is gonna use to try to
blast out Andy's hearing aid finally we
have the Caslon hub which is likely a
parody of the Google home hub from real
life and this is the central brain that
controls all of the Caslon products
throughout the house which can be used
by the touchscreen or voice operated and
if you look at the trailer the barclays
actually do have this in their home at
the bottom of the site you can enter
your email to get updates so if there
are any update emails or updates to the
website or arg in general I'll be sure
to make a video to keep you up to date
on any supplemental world-building for
this movie so if you want to stay up to
date remember to subscribe to see these
world for new Horrors every week bring
that death film for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive